good morning modern status it's a
beautiful morning this morning
today it's supposed to be like 90 for us
pretty woman for this part of the
country I got all the other animal
chores done the pigs have fed the
chickens are fed I hear the goats now
it's time to let them out see how they
did for their first night and try our
hand at okay let's see how this goes
- girls survived your first night
looks like you did huh here the pigs
don't think you get straw all over you
blossom
[Music]
see that were so bad was it
do you guys cleaning up after mom right
well oh that wasn't bad well oh well
that was the first time milker and so
are mine so that was pretty good yeah
we're gonna get better all right what
did I just learn from my first milking
experience first of all the tiniest
milking pill I could find is way too
tall for our Nigerian Dwarf goats so I'm
gonna have to order probably a shallower
but wider bucket I'll see if I can find
something on Amazon I'll start using
that willow is gonna be an awesome
milker we all just need to get used to
it but I am excited it's gonna be a
fun-loving learning curve I think it was
good this morning Oh what's the matter
you like your sausage Egg McMuffins now
yeah so much I wanna go yesterday
we're all upset
[Music]
[Applause]
pooped everywhere no that's what they do
they poop
[Music]
good did you sleep good blossom was
covered in straw so they must have slept
pretty good yeah they trip you up pretty
good
thank you goats want you what you doing
[Music]
hey give it on my ear nothing wrong you
calling the Rodney buy music button a
button
you gotta come out there links you're
scared
[Applause]
you girls like that I've been waiting to
prune those trees until you get here at
least that way we could do something
with them
well you made it out you didn't get too
far though
was she in the house the goats are
blatting so much more today Han Livi's
but she don't blossom and coming to say
hi
awesome figure it all out look at her oh
that's silly she can eat some hay and
she can also eat some apple tree leaves
she can can't see yep
get back
- girls like raisins you don't but your
goat does want some raisins
so what raisins
okay she's chewing her cud she's got to
swallow it in a minute
no she's gonna swallow it in a minute
okay she's swallow you gotta have some
stuff come up in a second and get
chipmunk cheeks here it comes
[Laughter]
[Music]
chewing the cud okay he's gonna be gone
a minute just swallow it no more left do
you like people watching you eat oh she
swallowed no she's taking so long that's
a big mouthful hey don't be doing that
lady to Newt I can't watch you do it in
there she's gonna get some in there yep
what's that
it's the freeway
karates uh yeah the beats aren't doing
too bad the tomato plants look awesome
what's that is it red red nope it's not
red red it's pink there's one over here
that's red red okay
first strawberry yes
yummy is it tart sweet sweet how's it
looking good I see 2 or 3 Tomatoes over
on this one 1 2 and I think I saw
another one but I can't find it now up 3
right here awesome
and a squashes and cucumbers or vice
versa doing good over here these ones we
started from seed and these ones we've
started in the outdoor kitchen and soil
blocks they're doing awesome and the
potatoes are looking good I'm excited
for the cabbage it seems to be doing
pretty good red cabbage and then the
green cabbage is on this side and I'm
not seeing any green cabbage I wonder
how long it'll be before we start
picking some string beans
you're crazy picked you really still
haven't gone out yet have ya
you chewed up the ramp I made with wood
chips don't you touch it I think the
chicken got zapped
it's time to try milking again so willow
did really good milking you god is good
probably a small cup load she's not used
to getting milked and I'm not used to
milking so and they're new here so I
don't know if it's right but I'm trying
to ease her into it though getting her
too upset and the kids upset that's my
thoughts if you have goat experience let
me know what you think of that idea
you're in the comments down below you
like your goat you want to return them
no now you want to keep them okay thanks
for coming along and our crazy journey
with us today I was here right back here
tomorrow at one my agent a guide to my
home setting so see you freedom
bye bye
[Music]